- [Mark] All right, Steve.
Let's hear bro,
where'd you grow up, where
are you from originally?
- [Steve] I originally grew
up in Los Angeles, California.
- [Mark] And tell me about your family,
you grew up with both your parents?
- No, I never had a father.
My mother, she was,
she was a good provider
but she was a lousy protector.
She didn't protect me from
people that would hurt me.
When I was abused throughout the years,
by my uncle,
he was a drug addict and alcoholic
and he would just go crazy on me.
And I was just a little boy.
I still have scars on my legs today,
from when he used to hit
me with a phone cords
and extension cords.
My mother, she would keep me
out of school for the week
because she was afraid
of children's services taking me away.
- [Mark] Cause somebody
would see the scars?
- Yeah, so she didn't let me go to school
because I was bleeding all in my head
and things like that.
And I didn't get it back
then, why she kept me
out of school, but now
that I'm older, I know why.
Because she was afraid
they would take me away.
I wish they would have, because maybe now,
I wouldn't be in this
situation that I'm in now.
I would have made better choices.
Just the same as if my father was around,
maybe somewhere down
the line he could have
guided me in the right direction.
And instead, I chose the streets.
I never finished high school.
I chose drugs and the
street life over my family.
I have children that are grown now.
I've been out of their lives,
I've never been a father.
I don't know how to be a father.
And I sort of blame my father,
but I can't put all the blame on him,
because I'm an adult now
and I know the difference
between right and wrong but,
I never had a father.
So I don't know how to be one.
- [Mark] How old are you now?
- I'm 40 years old.
- [Mark] And how old are your kids?
- My daughter, she will be 21 in March
I have two younger boys who are 13 and 11.
I have a 15 year old son.
I've never done anything for them.
- [Mark] Do you talk to them?
- I've talked to my
daughter, here and there,
but because I was never there for her,
she's doing her own thing.
You know, she's into the gang life.
And I blame myself for that.
Because if I would have been there,
maybe I could have stopped
her from joining the gang.
My two youngest boys, I was
in and out of their lives,
because I chose the streets,
over my family once again.
And their mom couldn't take
it anymore, so she let me go.
And I understand why.
I don't have much family.
I haven't seen my mother since 2011.
I have no idea where she is.
My grandparents don't know
where she is, no one knows.
Ever since my little sister passed away,
it's like she forgot about me.
She forgot that she
still has one child left.
- [Mark] How'd you lose your sister?
- I was told that she
was addicted to pills
and her whole internal
organs, everything shut down.
That's the story that was given
to me when I was in prison.
I was such a terrible brother to her.
And I felt so bad, when she passed away.
I still carry that guilt,
of treating her so bad.
Wishing I could go back
in time and change things
and be a brother to her.
I tell her all the time how sorry I am,
(sniffing)
for not being the big brother
that I should've been.
I couldn't stand my
sister, I don't know why,
I just couldn't.
I couldn't stand being around her.
And when she passed away,
I felt so bad.
The last time I saw
her, she came down here,
and she tried to get me to come home,
and she cried,
because I refused to get in the car,
and go home with her.
And that's the last time I saw her.
So that guilt, is always going to be,
(sighing)
I'm always going to feel that guilt,
of not going home with
my sister when she cried,
and she pleaded,
for me to come home and
get off the streets.
I don't know.
I need help.
I've been downtown for a long time.
And I don't know why I'm still here.
When I know I don't have to be.
(sniffing)
I'd give anything to start all over again.
To make the right decisions.
I've had people in my life,
that tried to guide me,
to do the right thing,
but I was already hooked on the streets,
the excitement, the lifestyle.
But now that I'm 40 years old,
it's not fun anymore.
It tears you down, it wears you out,
sleeping on the streets every day.
Sleeping in a tent or on a
sidewalk or something like that.
It takes a toll on your body.
The worst thing that happened
to me is when I was bit
by a brown recluse spider,
and it nearly took my arm off.
- [Mark] Where'd this happen?
- This happened,
- [Mark] Were you living on the street?
- Yeah, down here.
This happened,
2018.
My arm got really big
- [Mark] Where were you bit?
- On my elbow and it still hasn't healed.
- [Mark] Oh, why is your arm all dark?
Is that from the bite?
- That's from the skin graph.
- [Mark] Oh a skin graph.
- Yeah, they took color
off of my leg and I guess
put it on my arm
- Wow
- Because when they cut off
the flesh it was just pink.
So they did what they could with my leg
and put it on my arm.
- [Mark] Did you almost loose the arm?
- Yeah, it goes all the way up to here.
My whole entire arm.
- [Mark] Geez.
- It goes all the way up.
- [Mark] And that's from the spider bite?
- Yeah, it still hasn't
healed all the way,
and this is 2018.
But because I'm out here on the streets
and I'm not taking care of myself,
the way I need to the
process is taking longer.
- [Mark] What do you think
would have changed your path
when you were a kid?
Having your dad?
- I honestly think so.
I'm not going to say
that I would have made
the best decisions because he was there,
but something would have changed.
- [Mark] Having a dad who
was a good role model?
- Yeah.
Yeah.
Yes.
I feel so bad
because I let myself down.
I left my grandparents down.
Anybody that could ever cared about me,
I disappointed them.
They always had high hopes for me.
I was an honor roll student.
I didn't started making bad
grades until junior high school.
Once I started doing drugs and
hanging with the wrong crowd,
I would give anything to go back
and change that.
I started hanging out
with gangs at a young age.
Then I became a gang member, at one point.
But as I got older, I got tired of it.
There's no point in gang banging
because you're either going to jail,
or you're gonna die.
One of the two, there's no
benefits from gang banging.
None whatsoever.
I wanted to be a part of something.
I wanted to be in a family.
I feel like I'm out here all by myself now
because I don't know where my mother is.
And my father stays in Denver somewhere.
But he's never wanted to be
a part of my life anyway.
He's involved with all his
other children, but me.
I'm the only boy, he has all girls.
I'm the only one he
has nothing to do with.
And I don't understand that.
How could you do that to me?
I tried to be apart of his
life but he didn't want it.
He pushed me away.
Even my grandmother, his mom
would get upset
and talk to him about neglecting
me and things like that.
He would still,
leave me alone.
(sighing)
I just wanna start over again.
I'm 40 years old now and I
have nothing to show for it.
I've been to four different colleges
and I didn't finish any of them.
Because the streets kept calling me.
I kept going back to the streets,
thinking I can do both, and I can't.
And I see that now.
I'm what you would call
a dysfunctional addict.
I can't take care of my business and still
live that street life.
I'm not,
(sighing)
I can't do it.
- [Mark] What drugs do
you use, or have you used?
- Crack cocaine.
In the past I've used PCP.
Marijuana.
I've tried crystal, but
I don't really like it.
(sighing)
I just want to start over.
I want to go back to when
my sister was still alive.
She died when she was only 25
and I had no idea that she was sick.
So when I heard about
it, when I was in prison
it destroyed me.
Because all that guilt, just
came down on me at once.
I felt so bad for how I
treated her when we were kids.
And I tell her how sorry I am all the time
and tell her how much I love her.
(sniffing)
(sighing)
She will be 37
this August.
(sniffing)
And I miss her so much.
I would give anything just to hug her
and tell her how sorry I am
(sniffing)
(sighing)
Thank you.
(nose blowing)
(sniffing)
(sighing)
- [Steve] Downtown has been
the downfall of my existence.
Ever since I stepped foot down here,
it's been all bad for me.
(sniffing)
I can't, it's hard for me to stay away.
I do good for a little while.
And somehow I live kind
of back here, anyway.
(sniffing)
(sighing)
And I know my sister is,
disappointed in me
because I'm still here.
(sniffing)
(sighing)
I don't know what to do.
I'm not into the games anymore,
that's one thing I can say.
I don't know.
(sighing)
(sniffing)
I just,
I just want to start over, that's it.
(sniffing)
I can't believe I made
it to be 40 years old
after all the things I've done.
I've done a lot of things in
my life that I'm not proud of.
And majority of it is all drug-related.
- [Mark] What were you in prison for?
- First time I went to
prison was for a violation,
and then the second time I went to prison
was for a strong armed robbery.
It was all behind drugs, everything.
(sighing)
I gotta get clean.
I need help.
I've been in programs before,
but I never finish them.
I always leave the program
and things like that.
But, I'm starting to
think that maybe it's time
that I go to one and stay.
Nothing can happen, but good,
when you're in a program, I
mean, it's better than this.
(sighing)
I've never had a job for
more than six months.
I've never been able to hold a job,
because I, once again I
thought that I could live
my street life and still
take care of business.
It's all a lie, I can't do it.
And I've had that mind frame
since I was a teenager
thinking I can do both things.
And as you get older,
people start to care less,
because they see that,
or they feel that, you're
never going to change.
Your such and such years
old and you're still
doing the same thing.
So if I go to jail, I don't
have any support anymore.
Because the people that
care for me, they're tired.
They're tired.
They don't trust me anymore,
and I can't blame anyone but myself.
I caused this to happen.
I chose to do the drugs and drink alcohol
and things like that.
And do the things that
I've done in the past,
to make people not trust me.
(horns honking)
I wanna change.
(sniffing)
I wanna do something,
to make my kids proud.
And make my sister proud.
But most importantly to make myself proud.
(background voices chattering)
I gotta start somewhere.
I just don't know where to start.
I've been in jail more times downtown
than I've ever been in my whole life.
And it's all behind drugs.
(sighing)
I don't wanna die down here.
I've seen a lot of people die, down here.
Whether they were killed or
they died of natural causes
because they'd been out
here for a long time.
I don't want to be one of those people,
but I feel like I'm going to be one.
Because I'm still here.
(sighing)
Still here.
Well, if this is going
out to social media,
for those who are really paying attention,
don't take life for granted.
Cherish every moment that
you have with your family,
your children,
your mother, your father
your grandparents,
(sniffing)
because they can all be gone.
With the snap of a finger.
I have no more family,
I don't know where anybody is anymore.
My grandparents are dying.
(sighing)
And all they wanted me
to do is to do better.
And I can't even do that before they die.
(sighing)
So I just, stay away from them.
Cause I'm tired of disappointing them.
I don't want,
(sniffing)
(sighing)
I don't know.
My advice to all the parents out there,
watch your kids, very close.
Pay attention to their
activities and make sure
they're not hanging
around the wrong people.
Make sure you're not doing drugs,
or they'll end up like me.
- [Mark] Alright,
thank you so much for
talking to me and coming in.
(sighing)
(sniffing)
- Man,
I don't know what else to say,
I'm just, I get all emotional
once I started talking
about my grandparents and my kids,
and how I haven't accomplished anything.
The only thing I've accomplished,
was, to create more grief for myself.
(finders clicking)
(sniffing)
To all the parents,
love your kids as hard as you can.
Be there for them, listen to them.
Acknowledge them and let them
know that they can always come
to you when they need someone to talk to.
Never pushed them away.
Always lift them up.
That's all I can say.
(sniffing)
(sighing)
If any of my family is
out there watching this,
my children,
anyone, whoever cared about me,
I'm so sorry,
for not being there.
I'm so sorry for the huge
disappointment that I've become.
I'm sorry.
Please forgive me.
That's all I can say.
(sniffing)
- [Mark] Okay, thank you.
- Thank you.
(sighing)
Oh man.
- [Mark] You're a great speaker.
- Thank you.
(sighing)
I just get all emotional and
stuff when I talk about...